andrew cuomo renuncia luego de que la
fiscalía presentara una investigación en
la que se le acusaba de acoso sexual el
gobernador de nueva york inicia una
rueda de prensa
asumo toda la responsabilidad por mis
acciones
he sido muy familiar con las personas mi
sentido del humor puede ser insensible
mi renuncia será efectiva en 14 días a
mi equipo gracias gracias
a pesar de que en un principio el
gobernador negó las acusaciones este
martes cambió su discurso
beth guynn a white hay una diferencia
entre conducta indebida y acoso sexual
bullying sexual por asma
ahora no me malinterpreten esto no
quiere decir que no hay 11 mujeres a las
que realmente ofendí
las hay y por eso me disculpo
profundamente en verdad hay de play the
play tras su salida marca el declive de
mi carrera política que daba señales de
con demócratas podría perfilarse para
llegar a la casa blanca
[Música]
la renuncia llega después de que varios
líderes políticos entre ellos
personalidades de su propio partido e
incluso el presidente joe biden lo
presionaron para dejar su cargo como
anunció que su reemplazo será kitty hawk
u quien será la primera mujer en ocupar
este cargo queda la incógnita de saber
si el ex gobernador se deberá enfrentar
a un proceso penal o civil por dos
cargos de acoso sexual